bajo un Cielo gris este pueblo siberiano
está de luto por la muerte de uno de los
suyos su nombre era Nikita perlín murió
pocos días antes de cumplir 32 años en
algún lugar del frente de Ucrania no
tenía experiencia previa en la lucha
como cientos de otros jóvenes rusos fue
reclutado por orden del presidente Putin
a finales de septiembre
fue movilizado el 29 de septiembre cinco
días después estaba en Ucrania murió
Poco después
estamos muy disgustados estos hombres no
estaban en absoluto preparados fueron
enviados a Ucrania como Carne de cañón
la pequeña comunidad siberiana ha sido
arrastrada a una guerra miles de
kilómetros de distancia sin tener
elección en el asunto otros cuatro
jóvenes reservistas del distrito
murieron al mismo tiempo que Nikita
Berlín
su familia y amigos critican
abiertamente la forma en que fue
convocado y la torpeza de las
autoridades en el anuncio de su muerte
unos días después de su llegada a
Ucrania recibimos la noticia de su
muerte luego vino un oficial a decirnos
que era un error y que no sabían dónde
estaba una semana más tarde el ejército
llamó a su mujer para decirle que era él
quien había muerto
liderazgo deficiente falta de
entrenamiento y equipamiento en
respuesta a las crecientes críticas el
Ministerio de defensa ruso público el
vídeo de jóvenes reclutas en un campo de
entrenamiento cerca de San Petersburgo
el kremlin dice que 200.000 reservistas
han sido llamados desde finales de
septiembre para reforzar las filas del
ejército ruso ante la contraofensiva
ucraniana